moi je vous ai dit avec christop sur ma
sur la première des S plus grandent bah
c'est c'est la première fois de toute ma
carrière ça fait 25 ans que je fais de
la télé en 25 ans c'est la première fois
que je suis partie de l'ém à la fin de
l'émission Sans sans sans saluer mon
coanimateur et pourtant à TF1 j'étais
madame duo je faisais tous les duos avec
tous les animateurs de la chaîne
quasiment et je suis partie en claquant
la porte et c'est la première fois je ne
fais jamais ça j'ai pas de mouvement
d'humeur moi donc vraiment et et où
Étienne Moujotte à l'époque a appelé
Christophe en lui disant je serai toi
j'appellerai Valérie quand même parce
que ça serait bien que vous parliez que
voilà et Christophe et c'est pour ça que
je dis une fois que une fois qu'on dit
les choses tout s'est bien passé m'a
envoyé un petit mot souvent quand même
non mais en me disant je n'ai pas eu
conscience de ce que j'avais fait et à
quel point j'avais été dur et difficile
je te prie de m'en excuser un homme qui
s'excuse je trouve que c'est absolument
admirable et donc à partir qui s'est
déjà excusé d'avoir été dur un qui
s'excuse c'est admirable qui s'est
jamais excusé de ça non mais oui mais je
trve excuser et à partir de là on a
passé une année sans problème un connard
oui oui moi pas en tant qu'animatrice
parce que c'est pas mon métier mais en
tant qu'écrivain ouais j'ai eu un
problème avec Thierry Ardisson ah ouais
ouais ça avait été très violent j'allais
pour la promo d'un de mes livres don
tout le monde en parle c'était 2013 je
me souviens et non 2003 tout le monde en
parle et et en fait il me dit qu'on a un
problème technique et un problème de son
il faut que je répète le pitch de mon
livre et donc je répète trois fois et il
me dit dans l'oreillette Catherine Barma
me dit qu'on a un problème technique
donc il faut que vous répétiez s'il vous
plaît le pitch de votre livre donc je
répète je venais d'accoucher 5 jours
avant j'étais hyper fébrile à l'époque
c'est une grosse émission pour un auteur
et donc ben en fait il a gardé trois
fois au montage exprès mon pit et il m'a
fait passer pour une gourde ah ou et
j'avais trouvé ça hyper violent hyper
hum j'ai eu une EMO avec tiardisson moi
aussi V je vous raconte exuse avec qui
vous êtes je raconte je r je vous
raconte l'histoire je suis dans ma loge
cool je suis dans mal je faisais
l'émission on s'entendait bien avec
Thierry Ardisson vraiment bien tu vois
et ou et à l'époque c'est on était en
face Laurent rier moi Laur Laurent
faisait l'accès en face et on a eu des
petites déclarations dans la presse oui
truc ouais et moi maintenant et je dis
dit et je voulais je le dis à chaque
fois Laurent et moi c'est je pense que
c'est un de mes animateurs vraiment
préférés Laurent on en a discutéci et
c'est le seul mec Laurent rquy quand il
était un peu de tendu entre nous deux il
n dit viens on va prendre un café tous
les deux et puis comme ça on se dit tout
et c'est vrai que Laurent et depuis on
est devenu vraiment je l'adore et je
suis très très pote avec lui enfin je
j'aime beaucoup en tout cas pas pote on
s on s pas beau mais je l'aime beaucoup
voilà il est adorable avec tout le monde
vraiment ouais c'est un super mec
Laurent vraiment c'est un super mec Laur
et je suis dans ma loge et j'ai le
retour et je suis dans mal loge avec mon
bras droit j'ai deux bras droit j'en ai
plusieurs moà là c'est loï he voilà et
loï est à côté de moi et on regarde et
ils lui disent ouais cyil a dit on avait
dit j'ai dit je veux pas être sur le
même plateau que Laurent Laurent il y
avait Laurent qui t'invité je dit quand
Laurent s'en va je je viens et là il y a
Ardison je l'entends il sait pas que
j'ai le retour il dit bah il va fermer
sa gueule et il va venir ici et il va se
mettre à côté de rqu j'adore donc là je
dis je vois ça je suis dans ma loge donc
je dis si dit à Thierry de venir me voir
dans ma le c'est un bonheur donc donc je
lui dis euh je et donc il lui dit il
veut pas il faut pas il faut pas
descendre donc il faut monter le voir
donc il tion qui monte me voir dans là
je dis à mon ass à mon bras droit de
sortir et j'ai fermé la loge et on a une
petite discussion
et et finalement ça s'est très bien
passéour j'aiémission j'ai fa l'émission
vraie histoire histoire il é voilà et
donc depuis après après on on s'est
rabiboché pu j'ai voilà en tél voilà non
non mais c'est vrai j'avais parce que
j'ai pas aimé parce queis et donc voilà
c'est toujours moi je préfère moi je
préfère un mec devant moi qui me dis
voilà qui me dis non mais tu nous fais
chier il m'aurait dit c tu me fais chier
tu vas faire l'émission avec la mais
voilà là après c'est vrai que si vous al
vraiment si on devait vous trouver
vraiment on met tous des pincettes ici
je crois tout le monde un petit défaut
mais vraiment comme ça voilà je dirais
sanguin mais sanguin en deux mots c'est
pas puisqueprès les
me nous on a déjà eu des engueulettes de
ouf et 10 minutes après c'est Jeet bébé
perfectionist perctionist vous avez déjà
eu un al moi je me suis engueulé
violemment avec Benjamin Castaldi Mo
aussi aussi ouais je sais mais c'était
juste avant vous et il s'est couché au
téléphone donc ça a
été va le faire
venir raconous une vraie histoire
racontenous une vraie histoire une vraie
bah là non mais là c'est une vraie
histoire ça le ton était monté et une
engueulade monumentale avec Pascal pro
qui est un ami lors d'une émission On
refait le match mais monumental mais moi
aussi c'est un ami mais à pendant une
pause publicitaire mais des insultes on
était presque venu au on refait le match
avec J sacomano presque venu au main à
tel point que j'avais disjoncté
totalement j'avais
villétonnant non parce que je vrille pas
je me contrôle c'est vrai vous entendez
je me contrôle je ville pas et là moi tu
vois je dis moi je pense que tu vill
comme tes amis ce ne sont pas mes amis
on les connait à tel point ce ne sont
pas mes amis à tel point que j'avais
Villé complètement j'avais insulter un
entraîneur lors de l'émission ce qui m'a
valu un procès j'avais complètement pété
les plombs une fois ça m'est très
rarement arrivé depuis je ne sors plus
de mes gonss voilà sinon il y a Jo star
ou non là c'est lui c'est lui r fait cal
tu dis pas de btis toi tu t'es
embrouille avec qui moi j'ai une
embrouille avec
[Applaudissements]
guilux bon ça suff c'est
bon sur la F de
Zapata alors pour les plus jeunes gu
c'est qui aujourd'hui
c'est c vraiment LEP du top
c'était un boss des variétés franchement
et j'étais hyper impressionné j'étais
hyper impressionné j'avais ouf
jeouilléux écoutemo bien guilux je
commence à me faire
chier était très
dur j'avais 25 ans je l'attendais pour
passer un entretien il me fait attendre
1 he et deilux ouais il arrive il met
vraiment méprisant il me dit ah bah
c'est bien vous m'avez attendu vous êtes
patiente et alors faut vous dire que
j'étais à 25 ans j'étais habillé encore
moins moderne que maintenant donc
il me fait toute façon avec le look que
vous avez vous devez pas être très
occupé voilà donc cé
sympa
çaux auss qui s'est
embrouilléux suis je ne suis absolument
personnep je je suis personne à l'époque
et Patrick Sébastien a besoin d'un
auteur pour écrire un gars qui distribue
des calendriers de Bonne Année bon
j'écris quelques sketch a pour 4 ou 5
minutes c'était 1000 francs la minute
1000 francs 1000 ancien francs oui la
minute et guilux percevait en amont les
droits d'auteur donc moi j'attendais
juste qu' me rembourse l'argent qu'il
avait touché pas qu'il me paye hein
c'est à l'époque sa secrétaire je la
salue je l'embrasse c'est Marie
schneeder si tu nous regardes et donc
j'attends
j'attends un mois 2 Mo possible c'est
possible non tu es salot
sal j'attends j'attends un mois de mois
et dit il va il va peut-être vous donner
peut-être que 3000 elle me dit au
téléphone je l'ai au téléphone moi je
crève la dalle je ne suis absolument
rien jeamais fait une télé de ma vie et
puis ça passe ça passe et là elle dit
écoute écoutez Jean-Marie là il est là
Monsieur Lux elle me dit je vais lui
demander reprends le monsieur Lux
appelle et attends reprends le téléphone
elle me dit Monsieur luxe préférerait
donner que
1000 et moi j'ai dit comme on était
passé de 6000 à 1000 j'ai dit qu'il me
les donne maintenant parce que dans 2
mois c'est moi qui va lu devoir de
l'argent comme comme c'est parti et
ensuite et un coup je fais la je fais la
classe deviens la star de la classe il
fait une spéciale de la classe avec Jean
lefève tout ça machin et dit mon salaire
je dis mon salaire c'est quoi il me dit
c'est 1000 et moi j'ai demandé à mon
frère qui était à l'époque qui
travaillait pour moi je dis dit-lui que
Monsieur Bigard préférerait
[Applaudissements]